fray holland
daydreamer cat lover
new yorker on a fateful evening her life
changed drastically
when she was mysteriously transported to
the beautiful treacherous land of affia
whoa frey arrives with a magical
sentient bracelet inexplicably wrapped
around her arm oh hello yes and
discovers she can cast powerful spells
and use magic to swiftly traverse the
sprawling landscapes the last remnants
of atheist populace soon looked to fray
as their only hope for confronting the
tantas
once benevolent matriarchs who now rule
as maddened and evil sorceresses
reluctant to help but desperate to find
a way back home frey sets off on a
journey through this strange and
dangerous land
[Music]
the only safe haven in atheia is sepal
where refugees have gathered to escape
the mysterious corrupting force of the
break
some of atheist inhabitants will have
quests to give or information to share
others are willing to trade for valuable
goods
and frey may even find a small friend to
act as a guide
at this point in frey's journey she has
returned to sepal from the wilds after
finding a rare piece of advance
in the right hands this ore may prove to
be most useful
right
you've seen this stuff before
i've made armor out of it for tantasyla
no less
whoa you made that armor
does that mean you can do something cool
with this stuff
i could
but i'd need the right tools
and where can i find those
in prognost
huh
aren't there any in town i'll draw you a
map and give you the key you'll have to
do the rest yourself
if you can bring them back and that's a
big if
i'll make you something with that aura
of yours
outside the safety of sepal the only
life frey will encounter are corrupted
enemies looking to rip her limb from
limb
frey's combat spells make quick work of
low-level enemies
and her magic enhanced parkour abilities
turn this inhospitable land into her
personal playground
[Music]
treasure chests stop the landscapes and
contain items used for crafting or
trading with vendors back in sepal
mana is earned by leveling up but it can
also be found in glowing pools around
atheia collecting enough mana allows
frey to unlock new spells
[Music]
with the help of her golden companion
cuff
frey can scan belfries to reveal nearby
points of interest before continuing her
journey
this is the place on johiri's map isn't
it are you planning on retrieving her
smithing gear might as well while we're
here
besides i want to know more about sylha
and jokid
well as ever it seems we have a few
things to attend to first
yeah it looks that way let's break some
heads
[Music]
[Music]
looks like this is the place well here
we go
damn this stuff is heavy
the reassuring
[Music]
there is much to find in atheia so
exploring new locations before
completing a quest is always worthwhile
a variety of rewards are waiting to be
discovered or unlocked including
experience points
stat increases bits of affian lore and
new gear this thing just screams prop
why not try it on
[Music]
while frey is mysteriously immune to the
corrupting influence of the break
nothing else in atheia can escape its
grasp
humans are turned into savage zombies
and worse
while animals are mutated into dangerous
beasts
[Music]
pilgrims refuges are hideaways located
in every part of affia
and it's always a good idea to seek them
out
[Music]
here frey can craft healing drafts
upgrade gear
and get some much needed rest
[Music]
fully recharged and ready for the next
step of her journey frey travels onward
into the depths of corruption in
avalette
the effects of the break are even more
unmistakable here
and while frey may be resistant to those
effects
she will undoubtedly be pushed to her
limits
[Music]
this place is insane
so
frey will encounter numerous points of
interest in her travels
many of these landmarks and locations
have been corrupted or overrun with
corrupted enemies but they're always
worth seeking out
well this doesn't look good yes
something seems to have drawn the break
here but i expect you can clear it away
with your panels give it a try
[Music]
that's enough exploring for now
it's about time for frey to head back to
sepal and deliver the smithing tools to
joe hedy
all done
[Music]
what the hell is this
what did you expect a full suit of armor
you'd have needed a damn sight more or
for that
no i
it's cool i just
like you to lump it that's the last bit
of smithing i'll be doing for a while
[Music]
frey's journey will take her to the ends
of this beautiful cool land
and in her search for a way home
she discovers something worth fighting
for
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
is that a cat
you